[Music]
[Applause]
one of my favorite guests
has uh been rex chapman he was a high
school legend
legend of kentucky played 12 years in
the nba
fell victim to opioid and gambling
addictions which
ultimately led to his arrest in 2014 and
since then
rex has used his platform to share his
unique perspective
on what professional sports can push
someone
to become as well as overcome he's got a
podcast
it's called charges and uh he has a new
guest every tuesday
meta world peace michael vick ryan leaf
athletes who have gotten in trouble with
the law and uh
rex of course speaks firsthand with uh
the knowledge of that
great to see you buddy don't wanna
podcast look at you
thanks buddy uh yeah so much fun hey
i've been waiting since 11
20. am i doing one segment or two what's
going on
you're you're right yeah only my mom got
two segment tracks
not you do you remember when you took
that mug shot
and you put that mug shot attached to
your podcast just to let people know
hey i i've been there i've been jailed
you know
i i'm a famous guy and i'm here getting
a mud shot taken
yeah yes i remember it the mug shot
doesn't bother me so much i'm so
vain i'm just i'm just mad that i'm so
fat and
wait that's what you think when you see
it that's what i think immediately but
do you
think how like how big this is going to
be that it's going to go
national here yeah you know the lat
honest to goodness the last week has
been kind of
difficult emotionally just for me i
still tried to handle it the same way
just because i know
all of this stuff's going to be back out
there front and center in the public
again
and that's a little bit uh it's
unnerving
not only for me but for my kids
for my mom and dad you know that have to
kind of rehash all of that stuff again
so
from that standpoint yeah you're you're
controlling it this time
yes yes absolutely so uh you know look
dan i've been
i'm thrilled to be you know where i am
back here and
alive and and not on painkillers and
and finding you know new things about
life that
that i like and uh yeah i
i'm having a ball with it the i'm having
to learn how to interview
you know i can be interviewed i've done
this we and i we you and i texted about
it a few weeks ago i don't know how to
interview anybody so i'm just winging it
uh trying to be as vulnerable as i can
be to show them
hey you know come on give me give me
what you were feeling in that moment
you know when you were at your worst and
my goodness these guys have really been
uh willing to do that i've been really
pleased so far
are you revisiting though now you say
that
it's going to come up but when you talk
to these athletes
are you does it force you to kind of
tell your story to them so they know hey
we're on common ground here luckily so
far
everybody has known my story uh the you
know
i'm a little older yeah yeah you don't
have to tell me rex
we know that i saw that mug shot man you
look fat
i i really
uh yeah no i've reached out so far every
you know i reached out to allen iverson
and michael vick and immediately they're
like whatever you need bro
i'm in so it ryan leaf same way
it's been it's just been fascinating i
think
you know i know when i did it uh you
know talked about it last week
there is when you're in therapy and all
that
it's cathartic a bit and you know the
other part is
i know when i was searching out there in
the depths of my addiction and all that
i was just looking for
something anything any kind of
inspiration to show me that i could get
past it
and if if this something i say or
something one of these guests says
yeah it's through to somebody out there
that can get some help
take some steps maybe they wouldn't have
taken then hey okay that's great
do you remember like if you talk to
somebody who's used drugs they get that
that first feeling like that first and i
don't know if you remember that first
painkiller where you went oh wow and
and if you have a personality that you
know an addictive personality
like do you remember why you took it and
what that feeling was like
i really do uh because i i didn't i
wasn't a drinker i wasn't a smoker
even you know all through my career if i
went out and had a beer the night before
a game
a dozen times in my career oh yeah that
sounds about right i didn't
i wasn't that guy now i was always a
basketball addict
i was always a horse racing gambling
addict i was
um you know bag of jolly ranchers don't
give me one give me all of them i want
all of them and so when i finished
playing right away i had an emergency
appendectomy at the end of my last year
and i was going to stop playing after
that i wasn't very good anymore
and a doctor got off the
plane and the doctor gave me oxycontin
and for whatever reason i filled it i
i took it and in two days dan i for real
i was in love
i i felt i felt like i was walking a
couple inches off the ground
i felt smarter funnier happier
more charismatic better dad better
husband
um you know and just a terrible slippery
slope within
18 months i was taking 40 viking in a
day and 10 oxycontin a day just chewing
them up and eating them
all day long just like they were candy
thank goodness i didn't drink or i for
sure would be dead
so i i do remember it and it was i was
in love it was something that was
bigger than me before you know uh three
weeks
i was no longer determining when i was
taking that medicine the medicine was
telling me no you need me
you need me but when did you know
or did you know now all of a sudden
like i'm getting arrested for stealing
yeah
jesus uh yeah i mean at that point you
gotta know
uh i it was it was awful you know i've
got had two girls in middle school
too right out of out of high school
uh just the worst man um
you know so i'm i'm yeah i knew then i
knew before then i'd been in rehab
two other times before then but at that
point
you know i felt like i was at rock
bottom i'm
running low on drugs i'm running low on
money
um when i was with you one time
yeah yeah we were firing at the horses
were you were you high
for sure for sure and that's the that's
the part about it dan that
uh with with painkillers
it's it's sort of a perfect thing if
you're a drug addict because
you don't smell like weed and you don't
smell like liquor i would sweat a little
bit more a lot more
but you can kind of blend in to society
your decisions become worse and worse
over time
your physical and mental health becomes
worse and worse over time and
something had to happen to me i i i'm
not
uh i'm not happy that what happened
happened but something had to happen or
i was gonna die
yeah you wouldn't be here rex i mean the
embarrassment that was there but
now you're gonna help so many people
like
and i that's why i always love talking
to you because people
hear in your voice that you're real and
and if you truly want to help people
this is how you help people
i remember ryan leaf would say the
tip-off was he would start sweating
like i you know being in a family or a
family tree that
has you know alcoholics like
you always look at a tell like there's
tells and you could see
and somebody's drinking oh that's just
water it's not it's vodka like
so you're you guys are great liars like
great liars
and you have to be yeah addiction you
know you
and then there there comes a point too
in all of that and i know it did with
ryan because i just talked to ryan the
other day
uh you know there comes a point where
you're getting it from doctors and back
in the day any doctor would give it to
you if you just called up a random
doctor and
name dropped yeah i'm ryan lee for i'm
rex chapman they'd be like oh yeah what
do you need
and give your prescription now what
happens is pretty quickly
you can't keep up the doctors can't keep
up they start figuring out you go to
other doctors
pretty soon you run out of doctors
because you need so much and then you go
to drug dealers
and that's what i was doing for oh man a
good couple of years
early on just buying them off the street
and
the crazy part is that these illegal
drugs
they're not they come straight out of
the back of the pharmacies that's where
you find them that's where you go by
them from somebody inside
that's you know working double time
they're taking them out of the back and
selling them to somebody right out of
the back of uh
osco's or wherever the hell it is i was
worried
when i went through my knee surgeries
they gave me oxycontin when i had my
neighbor in place and i
and i i didn't take him like i was so
worried i didn't want to like them and i
knew i would
and i purposely was like i got to get
through like a couple of days here
that initial pain but you know that's
good dan i'm glad to hear you did that
my mom had
surgery knee surgery a little while ago
and there's so many people that i know
present day you know living around me
friends that i know
that have pain that
constantly have three or four pills in
their pocket they wouldn't
think and they they don't classify
themselves as addicts as drug addicts or
pill addicts or whatever
but they're never without a handful of
pills in their pocket
and that's so many people especially
where we grew up in ohio and kentucky
and
the midwest and south is just being
ravaged by it he's rex chapman former
nba player
and uh twitter legend by the way the new
podcast no you do a great job on twitter
you're fun uh the podcast is charges
made its debut this week uh so ryan leaf
meta world peace what did you so michael
vick did you do that interview already
haven't done it yet about to do it yeah
i'm excited really excited because i
you know with these guys i'm a big fan
too i'm a big michael vick fan
um i'm a big fan right ryan leaf i'm a
sports fan just like you guys
i remember dan i'll say this real quick
you remember when we were young there
was a big star
played played at ohio state i know you
remember this uh
arch schliester yeah and i just thought
he hung the moon you know
quarterback my goodness all american
dude had a
big time issue gambling still does
yes been in jail in and out of jail and
i thought back
i was like man because i always wondered
i was like
why don't you just stop gambling my the
little kid in me you know
uh it would have been beneficial for me
to hear
you interview art schliester back in the
day you know
so i i hope that us interviewing michael
vick and
pete ron our test meta sander for our
test i guess now
that you know somebody somewhere is
going to get something out of it
that's relatable sports is so relatable
and hopefully we can help some people
the advice that i'll give you is
ask open-ended questions short questions
open-ended questions get that person
talking
and i think once they get talking and
then they establish a comfort level
like that that's my goal every time is
get to the question because people want
to hear your answer and then
let you talk um and assume nothing
because i as many times as we've talked
and i might have answers
my audience might be hearing this for
the first time and i don't want to cheat
that you know that transaction there uh
but good luck with this thanks dan and
um
i don't know that's uh it's gonna be
pretty cathartic i hope for you how's
your jumper by the way when's the last
time you shot hoops
it's been a few months yeah i shot
outside with uh
some kids up the street not long ago and
i'm terrible i'm just terrible
i i you're not i'm terrible
uh you know you gave me some good advice
there dan i'm going to give you
something ready
don't don't sleep on john calipari of
the lakers that's all i'm saying
all right that's all i'm saying
were you and yes and yes i was high then
that was april of 2014.
[Laughter]
so so now that now we know you were high
when you
you put that out there poor calipari
is like i'm not going to the lakers wait
rex knows he's plugged into kentucky oh
what an idiot i might have said i think
rex must be high
and i didn't even know you were probably
i was just
kidding where can people get the podcast
anywhere man i heart radio i heart radio
it's on ihr
radio it's anywhere apple podcast
spotify find it anyway
charges charges with rex chapman awesome
thanks bud stay in touch thanks bud